From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Ira Glass is off this week, I'm Sean Cole.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，欢迎收听《美国生活》。Ira Glass本周休假，我是Sean Cole。
So there's this guy who's been on our show a few times now, Kirk Johnson. He's this extraordinary person. In his early 20s, he went to Iraq and ran rebuilding projects in Fallujah for USAID after the invasion. He saw that Iraqis who worked for the US military were being threatened and killed because of it and weren't getting asylum in the US. And he was outraged.
节目里有位嘉宾我们之前采访过几次，叫Kirk Johnson。他是一个非凡的人。20多岁时，他曾在美国入侵伊拉克后前往费卢杰，为美国国际开发署（USAID）管理重建项目。他看到那些为美军工作的伊拉克人因此受到威胁并被杀害，却无法在美国获得庇护，他对此感到极其愤慨。
So he single-handedly launched a campaign which changed US law on this. And for years after, he championed these cases, saving thousands of people's lives. It was beyond difficult, an extraordinary stressful job.
于是，他独自发起了一场运动，改变了美国在这方面的法律。在此后的多年里，他一直支持这些案例，挽救了数千人的生命。这非常困难，是一份压力极大的工作。
And so to decompress, Kirk took up fly fishing, which is where today's story actually starts. It has nothing to do with Iraq or refugees. It begins on a river in New Mexico.
为了放松，Kirk开始学习飞蝇钓，也就是我们今天故事开始的地方。这和伊拉克或难民毫无关系，故事始于新墨西哥州的一条河流。
Fly fishing, just in case you don't know, you're using this special lure that looks like an insect. That's the fly. It floats on the water. Kirk makes his own flies out of things like rabbit fur-- so taking parts of one kind of animal, using it to imitate another kind, in order to catch a third kind.
以防你不了解，飞蝇钓是指使用一种看起来像昆虫的特殊诱饵，那就是“飞蝇”。它漂浮在水面上。Kirk用兔毛等材料制作自己的飞蝇——也就是用一种动物的部分，去模仿另一种动物，为了捕捉第三种动物。
So Kirk's on the river with this guide, a guy named Spencer Seim. This is back in 2011. And at one point, Spencer reaches down to fetch something out of his tackle box. Here's Kirk.
Kirk和一位名叫Spencer Seim的导钓在河上钓鱼，那是2011年的事。当时，Spencer伸手去从渔具箱里拿东西。Kirk描述道：
And I caught this really colorful flash-- really beautiful looking fly. And I asked him what it was. And he pulls this thing out, and it's a salmon fly.
我看到一种色彩斑斓、看起来非常漂亮的飞蝇。我问他那是什么，他拿出了那个东西，那是一只鲑鱼飞蝇。
That is, it's used to catch salmon. Kirk had only ever seen trout flies, which are kind of brown or gray. But this thing was intricately tied together with bird feathers and silvery thread, maybe an inch and a half long, kind of a moth-sized peacock, like an Impressionist version of an insect or a dream about an insect.
也就是说，它是用来钓鲑鱼的。Kirk之前只见过鳟鱼飞蝇，通常是棕色或灰色的。但这个东西是用鸟类羽毛和银色细线精心捆扎在一起的，大约一英寸半长，像一只飞蛾大小的孔雀，看起来像是印象派画作中的昆虫，或者关于昆虫的梦。
And it's got these emerald, and canary yellow, and ruby-colored strips from feathers of these exotic birds, maybe 10 or 12 species in total. And they're arranged in this really ornate pattern where the hooklets and the barbules will connect to this. It's really nerdy, yes.
它有来自这些珍稀鸟类的祖母绿、金丝雀黄和红宝石色的羽毛条，总共有10到12个品种。它们以一种非常华丽的图案排列，小钩子和羽毛纤维连接在一起。是的，这非常极客。
But I'd never seen anything like it. It's a beautiful piece of art. And he then said to me-- he goes, well, if you think that's crazy, you should hear about this kid who just broke into the British Museum of Natural History to steal hundreds of these exotic birds for their feathers, which he sold to Victorian salmon fly tyers, because he wanted to buy a new golden flute.
但我从未见过这样的东西。这是一件美丽的艺术品。然后他对我说，如果你觉得这很疯狂，那你应该听听那个刚闯入大英自然历史博物馆偷走数百只珍稀鸟类羽毛的小子的故事，他把这些羽毛卖给维多利亚时代的鲑鱼飞蝇制作者，因为他想买一把新的金长笛。
An actual flute, a musical instrument made of gold.
一把真正的长笛，一种用黄金制成的乐器。
And as soon as he said that-- I mean, I'm not over-dramatizing the moment. I was in the middle of a cast when he was telling me this, and I just kind of froze. I was like, this is the craziest sentence I've heard.
当他说完那句话时——我不是在夸大那一刻的情绪。他在告诉我这些的时候，我正钓到一半，整个人都僵住了。我当时心想，这是我听过最疯狂的一句话。
Kirk started plying Spencer with questions on the spot. He wanted to know everything. So they went back to Spencer's place that night and looked up the kid's profile on Facebook. His name? Edwin Rist, R-I-S-T.
Kirk立刻开始向Spencer追问细节。他想了解一切。那天晚上他们回到Spencer的住处，在Facebook上查到了那个小子的资料。他叫Edwin Rist，R-I-S-T。
And even that didn't seem like a real name to me. It seemed like some 19th century-- you know, he's one of these Victorian boxers.
即使是这个名字对我来说似乎也不太真实。这听起来像19世纪的……你知道，他是那种维多利亚时代的拳击手。
Edwin had broken into the museum two years earlier in 2009. This was a branch of Britain's Natural History Museum in a little town called Tring. So Kirk starts Googling around to read everything he can find out about the case.
Edwin在两年前的2009年闯入了博物馆。那是大英自然历史博物馆在特林（Tring）小镇的一个分馆。于是Kirk开始上网搜索，阅读所有关于这个案件的信息。
But there wasn't much, just a few articles in the British press that covered the basics, which were-- Edwin Rist was from New York originally. He was in London studying music. He was exceptionally talented on the flute.
但能找到的信息不多，只有英国媒体上寥寥几篇基本报道：Edwin Rist原籍纽约，当时在伦敦学习音乐，在长笛方面才华横溢。
He was only 20 when he stole the birds, 299 of them. And not just any dead birds, they were from one of the most important collections in scientific history. And also, their feathers would fetch about a million dollars if he took them apart and sold them to salmon fly tyers-- which he did, some of them.
他偷鸟时只有20岁，一共偷了299只。而且不仅仅是普通的死鸟，它们来自科学史上最重要的馆藏之一。如果他把羽毛拆下来卖给鲑鱼飞蝇制作者，价值大约一百万美元——他确实也这么做了，卖掉了一些。
And he was caught. The police arrested him. And yet, somehow, he was now walking around free auditioning for orchestras in Europe. And a huge number of the birds were still unaccounted for.
他被捕了，警察逮捕了他。然而，不知为何，他现在竟然自由自在地在欧洲参加管弦乐团的试镜。而那些鸟中仍有很大一部分下落不明。
Kirk wanted to understand how this happened, that a 20-year-old flutist with no particular experience in museum larceny made off with some of the most precious specimens in the world. And he wondered where the missing birds were.
Kirk想弄清楚这一切是怎么发生的：一个20岁、毫无博物馆偷窃经验的长笛手，竟然能带着世界上最珍贵的标本逃之夭夭。他也想知道那些失踪的鸟在哪里。
Kirk's guide, Spencer, told him, if you really want to find those specimens, you should get yourself to the 21st annual International Fly Tying Symposium. It was in Somerset, New Jersey at the Doubletree Hotel and Conference Center. About a hundred people were there.
Kirk的导钓Spencer告诉他，如果你真的想找到那些标本，你应该去参加第21届国际飞蝇捆扎研讨会。地点在新泽西州萨默塞特（Somerset）的希尔顿逸林酒店会议中心。大约有一百人参加。
If you've been to any trade show, you can picture it, sort of a maze of booths selling all kinds of fly tying supplies, hooks, thread, feathers. And you can buy whole birds there, too.
如果你去过任何展会，你就能想象出那个场景，就像一个充满摊位的迷宫，卖各种飞蝇捆扎用品、鱼钩、鱼线、羽毛。你也可以在那里买到完整的鸟类。
I went into one guy's booth, and he had a pretty large box just full of parakeet heads. And all of their beaks were kind of open, like they were chirping at the moment of--
我走进一个人的摊位，他有一个巨大的盒子，里面装满了鹦鹉头。它们所有的喙都微微张开，好像在……的一瞬间还在鸣叫。
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
I won't go too gory there, but--
我不想说得太血腥，但是……
Were you about to say, at the moment of their death?
你是不是正要说，在它们死亡的一瞬间？
[LAUGHS] Yes, I was. I was actually going to say, at the moment of their decapitation. But there are bits of birds everywhere.
[笑] 是的，我确实是想说，在它们被砍头的一瞬间。到处都是鸟的碎片。
And the guy with the parakeet heads was busily tying a fly in a hook clamped in a little vise, and attached the feathers with thread, wrapping it around the shaft. All of these spectators were gathered around him like he was a sidewalk magician doing a trick. Kirk posed as a customer at first, but the guy could tell he wasn't serious about buying anything. So Kirk finally came clean and said to him that he was thinking of writing something about that museum heist.
那个卖鹦鹉头的人正忙着把飞蝇绑在夹在小虎钳上的鱼钩上，用线把羽毛缠在柄上。所有的观众都围着他，就像围观街头魔术师表演戏法一样。Kirk起初假装是顾客，但那人看得出他并不是真的想买东西。所以Kirk最后坦白说，他正考虑写一篇关于那个博物馆盗窃案的文章。
And he looks up from his fly, and he said, I don't think you want to write that story. And I said, no? Why? And he goes, because we're a small, tight-knit community. And you do not want to piss us off.
他从飞蝇上抬起头，说：“我觉得你不会想写那个故事的。”我说：“不吗？为什么？”他说：“因为我们是一个小而紧密的群体。你不会想惹恼我们的。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was just like momentarily stunned. But in my mind, I was like, holy cow, this is awesome. This is so--
我当时简直惊呆了。但在心里，我心想，天哪，这太棒了。这太……
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Because what would happen if you pissed them off?
因为如果你惹恼了他们会发生什么？
I don't normally pull this card out, but I feel like my time in Fallujah has calibrated my threat perception a little bit differently.
我通常不会亮出这张牌，但我感觉我在费卢杰的经历让我对威胁的感知有些不同。
I would imagine.
我能想象。
And so a dude with a bunch of feathers pinched between his fingers does not constitute a threat to me.
所以，一个手指间捏着几根羽毛的家伙，对我来说根本构不成威胁。
That guy's threat had the exact opposite effect on Kirk than he intended. And something kicked in for Kirk at this point, like it sometimes does when he gets an idea in his head.
那个人的威胁对Kirk产生了与预期完全相反的效果。Kirk体内的某种东西被激活了，就像他脑子里产生想法时有时会发生的那样。
To me, it was just a very clear-- you know, a flare fired. Like, if he was trying to turn me away from this story, it was like he had just filled my tank up. It was like, hey, pay more attention to this. This is crazy.
对我来说，这非常明确……就像发射了一枚信号弹。如果他想阻止我写这个故事，那感觉就像他刚刚给我的燃料箱加满了油。就像在说，嘿，多关注一下这个。这太疯狂了。
It is crazy, the stuff Kirk found out. You can't turn away once you start hearing all the details, not just about the heist and risk, but where the birds came from and the whole surreal subculture of salmon fly tying, what Kirk calls the feather underground, sometimes characterized by shady dealings and obsession. Kirk interviewed more than 50 fly tyers and discovered things that the people investigating the case didn't find out. And that is our show today, the story of what may be the greatest feather caper in history. Expect high drama and ornithology. And stay with us.
这确实很疯狂，Kirk发现的事情。一旦你开始听到所有的细节，你就无法回头了，不仅仅是关于盗窃案和风险，还有那些鸟的来源，以及鲑鱼飞蝇捆扎这种超现实的亚文化，Kirk称之为“羽毛地下世界”，有时伴随着阴暗的交易和痴迷。Kirk采访了50多位飞蝇捆扎者，发现了调查人员没有发现的事情。这就是我们今天的节目，关于历史上可能最伟大的羽毛盗窃案的故事。准备好迎接高度的戏剧性和鸟类学知识吧。请继续收听。
Act One, The Specimens. A quick warning that this episode contains a few swear words that we've un-beeped for the podcast version. You can find a version with beeps at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
第一幕，标本。一个小小的警告，这一集包含了几个在播客版本中没有进行哔声处理的脏话。你可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 找到带有哔声的版本。
The birds Edwin stole, I said they were valuable. Some of them were collected in the mid 1800s by one of the greatest scientific explorers of his time, a man named Alfred Russel Wallace. He was like another Darwin and a peer of Darwin's.
我刚才说Edwin偷的那些鸟很值钱。其中一些是19世纪中期由当时最伟大的科学探险家之一，一个名叫阿尔弗雷德·罗素·华莱士（Alfred Russel Wallace）的人收集的。他就像另一位达尔文，是达尔文的同行。
Alfred Wallace spent nearly a decade thrashing through the Malay archipelago, capturing and preparing animal specimens, and shipping them back to England. He lived in tiny huts, his flesh regularly invaded by bugs. And about four years in, he contracted malaria and figured he would just hunker down in his shack to sweat it out.
阿尔弗雷德·华莱士在马来群岛跋涉了近十年，捕获并处理动物标本，然后运回英国。他住在简陋的棚屋里，皮肤经常被虫子叮咬。大约四年后，他患上了疟疾，心想他只能蜷缩在棚子里，让汗水排走病痛。
And while he's in the middle of this fever, he has a eureka moment and figures out evolution through natural selection completely on his own. He's like, I've got it. Like, I figured it out.
就在高烧期间，他灵光一闪，完全独立地发现了自然选择进化学说。他心想，我明白了，我自己想通了。
And this is before Darwin came up with it?
这是在达尔文提出它之前吗？
Well, but this is the kicker. He sits down, and he writes this paper meant for publication. And he puts it in an envelope, and he mails it to Charles Darwin--
关键就在这儿。他坐下来写了一篇打算发表的论文，装进信封，寄给了查尔斯·达尔文——
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
--who had never published anything on this yet.
——而达尔文当时还没有发表过任何相关作品。
Darwin had figured it out, too, at that point, but he had been too scared to put it out there. These specimens were as important as Darwin's finches-- which, by the way, are also at the Tring Museum. They're early evidence of evolutionary theory. And specimens like these can inform scientists about everything from climate change to the way we perceive color. Scientists are still using them.
达尔文当时也想通了，但他太害怕公之于众了。这些标本和达尔文的雀鸟一样重要——顺便说一下，那些雀鸟也在特林博物馆。它们是进化论的早期证据。像这样的标本可以为科学家提供从气候变化到我们感知颜色方式等各方面的知识。科学家们至今仍在使用它们。
Alfred Wallace himself once wrote that each species, each bird, is an individual letter building the words and sentences that describe the deep history of our planet. If we allow these letters to disappear, that history disappears with them. He also wrote that it's probably best if people from the West never see birds like these in their original habitat in all their beauty and glory because they'd just plunder them and ruin everything. He had no idea how right he would turn out to be.
阿尔弗雷德·华莱士本人曾写道，每一个物种，每一只鸟，都是描述我们星球深厚历史的单词和句子中的单个字母。如果我们让这些字母消失，那段历史也会随之消失。他还写道，西方人最好永远不要在原生栖息地看到这些美丽的鸟，因为他们只会掠夺它们并毁掉一切。他当时根本不知道自己会错得有多离谱。
Not long after, there was an industrialized slaughter all over the world. And it was in the name of women's fashion.
不久之后，全球范围内出现了一场工业化的大屠杀。而这正是以女性时尚的名义。
This was back when women wore a lot of hats. And anyone who was anyone wore hats with a lot of feathers on them, from parrots, egrets, ospreys. Designers in the US and Europe couldn't get enough of this stuff. Whole species were decimated by the fashion industry. You'd see hats decorated with entire birds.
那时女性戴很多帽子。而任何有身份的人戴的帽子上都有大量的羽毛，来自鹦鹉、白鹭、鱼鹰。美国和欧洲的设计师对这些东西的需求量巨大。整个物种都被时尚产业摧毁了。你会看到装饰着整只鸟的帽子。
In the 19th century, this was like the Gucci bag. If you could only afford a robin, that was one thing. But if you could afford a bird of paradise-- and we're talking about the whole bird being mounted with outstretched wings. And sometimes, these hats had several different birds mounted on them.
在19世纪，这就像今天的古驰包。如果你只能买得起知更鸟，那是一回事。但如果你能买得起极乐鸟……我们说的是把整只鸟张开翅膀装上去。有时，这些帽子上装有几种不同的鸟。
Holy crow. [LAUGHS] Sorry.
天哪。[笑] 对不起。
And it's-- I mean, it is punny, but it was how they demonstrated their own perch in society.
这是……我是说，这是一个双关语，但这正是她们展示自己在社会地位的一种方式。
Some women had so many birds on their hats that they had to squat just in order to fit into their carriages-- so gaudy and inconvenient. Meanwhile, the gentlemen of the era were also sort of using feathers as accessories. Salmon flies were like hats for guys.
有些女性帽子上的鸟太多，以至于她们不得不蹲着才能坐进马车——如此浮夸且不便。与此同时，当时的绅士们也把羽毛当作配饰。鲑鱼飞蝇就像男人的帽子一样。
This was also around the time that all these exclusive fishing clubs were popping up on the coasts of England and Scotland. And each club had its own special patented salmon fly. And the flies themselves had all these names.
大约也是在那个时候，所有这些高级钓鱼俱乐部开始在英国和苏格兰海岸涌现。每个俱乐部都有自己专利的特制鲑鱼飞蝇。而这些飞蝇都有各种名字。
They're absurd. They're like the Exordium, the Jock Scott, the Durham's Ranger. Can I-- I just wanted to--
它们很荒谬。它们叫什么“序言”（Exordium）、“乔克·斯科特”（Jock Scott）、“达勒姆游侠”（Durham's Ranger）。我可以……我只是想……
Please.
请吧。
Can I just--
我能不能……
Yeah, yeah.
可以，可以。
Just to give people a sense of-- OK, so this is the recipe for the first salmon fly that Edwin ever tied. It's called the Durham Ranger. This is a recipe from the 1840s.
只是为了让人们感受一下……好的，这是Edwin绑的第一只鲑鱼飞蝇的配方。它叫“达勒姆游侠”。这是1840年代的配方。
And they call it a recipe?
你们管这叫配方？
Yes. The tail calls for feathers from the Indian crow, which is the red rough fruit crow that's all over South America. The butt requires two turns of black ostrich hurl. The throat has light blue hackle, usually from the cotinga, which is from Central America. The wings have a pair of long jungle cock feathers with double tibbetts on both sides.
是的。尾巴需要印度乌鸦的羽毛，也就是南美洲到处都是的那种红绒果鸦。底部需要两圈黑色鸵鸟绒。喉咙部位有浅蓝色的颈羽，通常来自中美洲的伞鸟。翅膀有一对长长的丛林鸡羽毛，两侧带有双Tippet（一种羽毛）。
And it goes on like that. The cheeks are from a bird called a chatterer. The horns are blue macaw, which is a parrot.
以此类推。脸颊部分来自一种叫“喋喋鸟”（chatterer）的鸟。角是蓝金刚鹦鹉的羽毛，也就是一种鹦鹉。
Of course, back then, when you wanted these feathers, you went down to the local plume merchant-- or in Paris a plumassier-- and you paid real money. Around the year 1900, certain snowy egret feathers were more expensive than gold.
当然，在那个时候，当你想要这些羽毛时，你会去当地的羽毛商那里——或者在巴黎叫Plumassier——花真金白银购买。1900年左右，某些雪鹭的羽毛比黄金还要昂贵。
But for me, all I kept fixating on was that this is all bullshit.
但对我来说，我一直纠结的是，这一切都是胡扯。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There's no reason why a salmon should care about any of this. They don't. I mean, you could tie a chocolate wrapper to a hook and catch salmon.
鲑鱼根本没理由在乎这些。它们不在乎。我是说，你可以把巧克力包装纸绑在钩子上，照样能钓到鲑鱼。
Oh.
哦。
So all of these little subtleties of which subspecies did you use for the cheek of the feather, they don't even see any of that.
所以所有这些关于“脸颊部位用了哪个亚种”的微小细节，它们根本看不出来。
But that didn't matter to Victorian salmon fly tyers back then. And these days, the community tying this kind of fly still tries to do it according to the same classical recipes in these 100-year-old manuals. Except now, they don't even fish with them. They're just for show.
但这在当时的维多利亚时代鲑鱼飞蝇制作者眼中并不重要。如今，这个捆扎飞蝇的群体仍然试图按照这些百年老书中的经典配方来制作。只不过现在，他们甚至不用这些飞蝇去钓鱼。它们只是为了展示。
They use feathers from the same species arranged the same exact way. So the fixation is on historical authenticity, like a fly tying version of civil war reenacting. But because we've murdered so many birds for so many reasons over the years, a lot of the most coveted species are now endangered or protected.
他们使用来自相同物种的羽毛，按完全相同的顺序排列。所以他们痴迷于历史的真实性，就像飞蝇捆扎界的美国内战重演。但因为多年来我们为了各种原因杀害了太多的鸟类，许多最令人垂涎的物种现在都濒临灭绝或受到保护。
There's a species of cotinga that is just completely illegal to buy and sell. It's the Cotinga maculata. And they completely jones over this stuff. I have been struggling to find another hobby whose adherents are so quickly driven to break international laws to do the art. I mean, you don't get into the dark side of knitting.
有一种伞鸟完全被禁止买卖。那是白翅伞鸟（Cotinga maculata）。他们对这些东西非常痴迷。我一直在努力寻找另一种业余爱好，其追随者会如此迅速地为了艺术而触犯国际法律。我是说，针织爱好者里可没有黑暗面。
Of course, not every salmon fly tyer is breaking the law, but some of them openly flout the rules or just ignore them. Violators can be fined thousands of dollars.
当然，并非每个鲑鱼飞蝇制作者都在违法，但有些人公开无视规则，或只是无视它们。违规者可能会被处以数千美元的罚款。
There was a post on the main web forum for this hobby, classicflytying.com, that sums up this slavish addiction to certain feathers. One guy said, there's something to a fly tied with the old materials.
在这个爱好最主要的网络论坛 classicflytying.com 上有一篇文章，总结了这种对特定羽毛的奴性成瘾。一个人说：“用老材料绑出来的飞蝇确实有一种‘东西’。”
And someone else responded, I've met this something. I'm haunted by it constantly now. It's like a drug. Nothing else matters. Nothing else compares. When it touches my fingers, I feel the history. I'm taken back to a time when fish were as big as logs, fresh from the sea, reds, yellows, and shades of blues. Their texture and color have that power to push you to do your best. There is nothing else that compares to that power.
另一个人回复道：“我也遇到过这种‘东西’。我现在一直被它困扰。它就像毒品。其他一切都不重要了，其他一切都无法与之相比。当它触碰我的手指时，我感受到了历史。我被带回到了那个鱼像原木一样大、新鲜从海里捞上来、红色、黄色和蓝色色调的时代。它们的质感和颜色有一种推动你做到极致的力量。没有其他任何东西能与那种力量相比。”
Act Two, The Flutist.
第二幕，长笛手。
[FLUTE MUSIC PLAYING]
[长笛音乐响起]
Kirk wanted to talk to the bird thief, Edwin Rist. He emailed him every now and then over the course of three years, asking for an interview. Edwin always said, no, that it was still too raw. And then finally, he agreed, gave Kirk like a week's notice. Kirk and his wife Marie-Josée flew to Dusseldorf where Edwin was living playing in an ensemble, which is the music you're hearing right now.
Kirk想和那个偷鸟贼Edwin Rist谈谈。他在三年里不时地通过邮件联系他，要求采访。Edwin总是说不，说这件事对他来说仍然太沉重。最后，他终于同意了，给了Kirk大约一周的通知。Kirk和妻子Marie-Josée飞往杜塞尔多夫，Edwin当时住在那儿，在一个乐团演奏，这就是你现在听到的音乐。
[ENSEMBLE MUSIC PLAYING]
[室内乐团音乐响起]
But Marie-Josée was worried. They didn't know this guy. He had broken into a museum, after all. Who knew what he was capable of, if he was dangerous? And they were meeting him at their hotel room.
但Marie-Josée很担心。毕竟，他们不了解这个人。他闯入过博物馆。谁知道他有什么本事，如果他有危险怎么办？而且他们是在酒店房间里见他。
So they hired a German bodyguard who sat out in the hallway during the eight-hour interview. They needn't have bothered. Edwin, while tall, was not imposing, even in his black pea coat.
于是他们雇了一名德国保镖，在八小时的采访期间坐在走廊里。他们完全没必要这样做。Edwin虽然高大，但并不令人畏惧，即使穿着黑色呢子外套也是如此。
He was friendly. Kirk liked him, though they're very different, Kirk's, oh, gosh farm boy Midwestern-ness and Edwin's living in a rarefied world of flutes and feathers in Europe. We asked Edwin if we could air parts of their interview on the show, and he said, no. So you won't hear his voice.
他很友好。Kirk喜欢他，尽管他们截然不同：Kirk是那种有着中西部农民气质的人，而Edwin则生活在欧洲长笛和羽毛的稀有世界里。我们询问Edwin是否可以在节目中播放采访的片段，他说不。所以你不会听到他的声音。
But a lot of what we know about how he came to be in the museum that night comes straight from him. He grew up in a quiet town in New York State south of Albany. He was cute, looked sort of like Harry Potter with thick, wire-rim glasses, a bit of an indoors-y kid, home schooled along with his younger brother.
但我们所知道的他那天晚上是如何进入博物馆的大部分内容，都直接来源于他。他在奥尔巴尼以南的纽约州一个安静的小镇长大。他长得很可爱，戴着厚厚的金属框架眼镜，看起来有点像哈利·波特，是个宅男，和弟弟一起在家接受教育。
And even back then, he was shaping up to be a great musician. Edwin's parents were both journalists. And when Edwin was about 10, his dad was researching a story for Discover Magazine about the physics of fly casting. So Edwin happened to watch an instructional video on how to tie flies using this specific kind of feather called a hackle.
即使在那时，他也已展现出成为一名伟大音乐家的潜力。Edwin的父母都是记者。Edwin大约10岁时，他父亲正在为《探索》杂志研究关于飞蝇抛投物理学的报道。所以Edwin碰巧看了一段教学视频，演示如何使用一种特定的叫“颈羽”（hackle）的羽毛来绑飞蝇。
--but let's tie the hackle around the base of the wing so that it floats lower in the surface and perhaps looks like a mayfly at rest.
……但让我们把颈羽绕在翅膀底部，这样它在水面上浮得更低，或许看起来就像休息的蜉蝣。
And the feather is transformed. It's suddenly, the hook has like a thousand little legs sticking out in every different direction.
于是羽毛发生了转变。突然间，鱼钩就像长出了成千上万条伸向四面八方的小腿。
Oh, it looks like a centipede, kind of.
哦，它看起来有点像蜈蚣。
Yes. And for whatever reason, 10-year-old Edwin's brain was just frozen by this. Seeing something so ordinary transform into something extraordinary like that was amazing to him.
是的。不管出于什么原因，10岁的Edwin的大脑被震撼住了。看到如此平凡的东西转变成如此非凡的东西，这让他感到惊叹。
Edwin told Kirk that he and his brother watched that part of the video maybe eight times. And soon, he was rummaging through the garage and the basement looking for a hook and thread, anything he could find to try it himself. He plucked the feathers from his mom's down pillow.
Edwin告诉Kirk，他和弟弟把那段视频看了大概八遍。不久之后，他就在车库和地下室翻找鱼钩和线，想尽一切办法自己尝试。他从妈妈的羽绒枕头上拔下羽毛。
His dad, seeing all of this, finally brought Edwin to a tackle shop, got him a vise, and some hooks, and other materials, so he could start tying flies for real-- trout flies to begin with, the ugly ones. Edwin's brother got into it, too. They took classes, spent hours hunkered over their creations in this kind of fuzzy trance.
他父亲看到这一切，最终带Edwin去了渔具店，买了虎钳、鱼钩和其他材料，让他可以真正开始绑飞蝇——起初是鳟鱼飞蝇，那些丑陋的飞蝇。Edwin的弟弟也参与了进来。他们上课，花几个小时专注于他们的创作，陷入一种模糊的恍惚状态。
Before too long, they were winning fly tying competitions and going to conventions. And it was at one of those conventions where Edwin laid eyes on his first salmon fly. It was at the booth of a prominent fly tyer named Edward Muzeroll, or Muzzy for short. And once again, little Edwin's mind just froze. It was the same reaction Kirk had that day on the water, total bedazzlement.
没过多久，他们就开始赢得飞蝇捆扎比赛并参加大会。正是在其中一次大会上，Edwin看到了他的第一只鲑鱼飞蝇。那是在一位著名的飞蝇制作者Edward Muzeroll（简称Muzzy）的摊位上。再一次，小Edwin的思维定格了。那是Kirk那天在水面上看到的同样的反应，完全被震住了。
And he's kind of oohing and aahing. And he starts talking to Muzzy. And then, before you know it, he's arranging for private lessons with Muzzy to learn how to do this new type of fly tying-- new to Edwin. And so I think he was 14 when he went up to Maine one summer and got lessons. I think it was eight or 12 hour days where Muzzy proceeded to walk him through not just the techniques but the history of this art form.
他当时有点“哦哦”惊叹。然后他开始和Muzzy交谈。没过多久，他就安排了向Muzzy一对一私人课程，学习这种对Edwin来说全新的飞蝇捆扎方式。我想他14岁那年夏天去了缅因州上课，大概是每天8到12个小时，Muzzy开始不仅教他技术，还教他这种艺术形式的历史。
During that first tutorial with Muzzy, though, where Edwin tied the Durham Ranger, they used substitute feathers or subs, meaning no red-ruffed fruitcrow, no black ostrich herl. Instead, they used, like, dyed chicken feathers or whatever. And Muzzy, who'd been tying flies longer than Edwin had been alive, could tell right away that Edwin was a natural, a prodigy.
在向Muzzy学习的第一次课程中，Edwin绑了“达勒姆游侠”，他们用了替代羽毛，也就是没有用红绒果鸦，也没有用黑色鸵鸟绒。相反，他们用了染色的鸡毛之类的东西。Muzzy（绑飞蝇的时间比Edwin出生的时间还长）立刻看出Edwin是个天才。
And so at the end of that first session, when Muzzy's saying goodbye, he gives Edwin an envelope and kind of in hushed tones said, this is what it's all about.
于是在第一阶段结束时，当Muzzy道别时，他给了Edwin一个信封，语气低沉地说：“这就是关键所在。”
Edwin opens the envelope. And inside is $150 or $200 worth of exotic bird feathers.
Edwin打开信封，里面是价值150到200美元的珍稀鸟类羽毛。
From the red-ruffed fruitcrow and from cotinga, I think. Now Muzzy's stuff was legal. And it was a gesture to this young acolyte, almost like, work your way up to these things. You know? Like, when you get good enough, try using one of these red-ruffed fruitcrow feathers.
我想有红绒果鸦和伞鸟的。Muzzy的东西当时是合法的。这是给这位年轻信徒的一种姿态，就像是，“慢慢来，等你练得够好了，再尝试使用这些红绒果鸦的羽毛。”
And that's when Edwin caught the bug. All he wanted to use in his flies were exotic bird feathers from then on. He started doing chores for his neighbors, gathering firewood, just for a little extra feather money. He soon grew into a master fly tyer-- which, by the way, means an expert mimmicker-- able to consistently and perfectly hew to the same classic recipes again and again. But there was always this one limitation as to what he could accomplish.
就在那时，Edwin迷上了。从那以后，他只想在飞蝇上使用珍稀鸟类的羽毛。他开始帮邻居做家务、收集柴火，只是为了多攒点买羽毛的钱。他很快成长为一名飞蝇捆扎大师——顺便说一下，这意味着他是一名模仿专家，能够始终如一地、完美地遵循相同的经典配方。但他所能达到的成就总是有一个局限性。
As good as Edwin got-- and I mean, he was heralded as the future of fly tying by Fly Tyer Magazine, which I subscribe to.
尽管Edwin变得很出色——我的意思是，他被我订阅的《飞蝇制作者》杂志誉为飞蝇捆扎界的未来。
Of course, you do.
当然，你是订阅了。
You know, he was completely embraced by this community by his 16th birthday, I think. I mean, he was a legend already. But as good as he was, he was a 16-year-old who wasn't really flush with cash.
你知道，我想在他16岁生日时，他已经被这个群体完全接纳了。我的意思是，他已经是传奇了。但无论他多出色，他都只是一个手里没多少钱的16岁孩子。
And so whenever there were these occasional eBay auctions of the species that he wanted, he always got outbid by these wealthier, older fly tyers who had disposable income. And so his devotion to this art form was kind of always defined by a longing for what he didn't have. These other guys would say, yeah, well, it's a good fly, but talk to me when you get some real cotinga.
所以每当eBay上偶尔拍卖他想要的物种时，他总是被那些更有钱、年纪更大的飞蝇制作者压价，因为他们有闲钱。所以他对这种艺术形式的追求总是被对他所没有的东西的渴望所定义。其他人会说：“是的，这飞蝇不错，但等你弄到真正的伞鸟羽毛再来跟我说话吧。”
That's not going to feel that good.
那感觉一定不好受。
No.
不。
Especially to a kid. Edwin has this specific way of talking, perhaps cultivated from living in Europe for many years. And on the topic of using substitute feathers instead of the real thing, he told Kirk, the knowledge of its falsity eats at you.
尤其是对一个孩子来说。Edwin有一种特殊的说话方式，可能是由于在欧洲生活多年培养出来的。在讨论使用替代羽毛而不是真品时，他告诉Kirk：“虚假带来的愧疚感会吞噬你。”
So in a way, Edwin was a pauper musician gazing through a shop window at a shiny musical instrument-- which, by the way, he literally was that, too. At the same time he was excelling at fly tying, he was also excelling at the flute. Just to give you a sense, this is a YouTube video Edwin posted of him covering "Master of Puppets" by Metallica, playing all the parts on different flutes.
所以从某种意义上说，Edwin就像一个在商店橱窗外凝视闪亮乐器的贫穷音乐家——顺便说一下，他本质上确实就是那样。在他擅长飞蝇捆扎的同时，他也擅长长笛。为了让你有个直观感受，这是Edwin上传到YouTube的视频，他在视频中翻唱了Metallica的《Master of Puppets》，用不同的长笛演奏了所有的声部。
[MUSIC - "MASTER OF PUPPETS" BY METALLICA]
[Metallica的《Master of Puppets》音乐响起]
Anyway, he was finally admitted to the Royal Academy of Music in London, but he didn't bring any of his fly tying gear or feathers with him. He said, Customs wouldn't have appreciated his birdy bag.
总之，他最终被伦敦皇家音乐学院录取，但他没有带任何飞蝇捆扎设备或羽毛去那里。他说，海关可不会欣赏他的“鸟包”。
Around the same time, a fly tying friend in Canada-- and something of a mentor to Edwin-- sent him an email saying basically, hey, while you're over there, you've got to check out this place north of London, a branch of the Natural History Museum in a town called Tring. He attached pictures of drawers filled with brilliantly colorful bird specimens. They weren't on display. They were stored away in a special wing of the museum that the general public isn't allowed into.
大约在同一时间，一位在加拿大的飞蝇捆扎朋友——也是Edwin的导师——发邮件给他，基本上说：“嘿，既然你在那边，你一定要去看看伦敦北边的一个地方，在特林小镇的一个自然历史博物馆分馆。”他附上了装满绚丽多彩鸟类标本的抽屉的照片。它们没有公开展出。它们被存放在博物馆一个禁止公众进入的特殊侧厅里。
Act Three, The Museum. The Tring is this big, old brick Tudor building from the 1880s. On the outside, it looks more like a private mansion or a boy's school than a museum. The only way you can see that special bird collection is for legitimate research purposes.
第三幕，博物馆。特林博物馆是一座建于1880年代的宏伟古老红砖都铎式建筑。从外观上看，它看起来更像私人豪宅或男校，而不是博物馆。参观那个特殊鸟类收藏的唯一途径是出于合法的科研目的。
So Edwin came up with a plan, a lie. He emailed the museum and told them he needed to photograph the birds for a friend's PhD thesis. And on November 5, 2008, he brought a camera to the museum, signed the visitor logbook using his own name, and was escorted to the Birds of Paradise Collection.
所以Edwin编造了一个计划，一个谎言。他给博物馆发邮件，说他需要为朋友的博士论文拍摄这些鸟。2008年11月5日，他带着相机来到博物馆，在访客登记簿上签下真名，并被带到了极乐鸟收藏区。
You can tell a research specimen of a bird from a mile away. Their eye sockets are stuffed with cotton, their wings folded down at their sides, legs stiff. They're referred to as bird skins. And importantly, the legs have these tags attached to them with the species, and date, and other bio-data, and, in this case, Alfred Wallace's signature.
你一眼就能认出鸟类的科研标本。它们的眼眶里塞着棉花，翅膀折叠在身体两侧，腿部僵硬。它们被称为“鸟皮”。重要的是，它们的腿上附有标签，注明物种、日期和其他生物数据，在这种情况下，还有阿尔弗雷德·华莱士的签名。
Without that tag, the specimen isn't a specimen anymore. It's just a bird. Who knows where the hell it came from? But research, of course, was the last thing on Edwin's mind, looking at the birds. He was just in awe of their arresting beauty.
没有那个标签，标本就不再是标本了。它只是一只鸟。谁知道它到底来自哪里？但Edwin看着这些鸟时，科研当然是他脑子里最后想的事情。他只是被它们迷人的美所震撼。
He made this analogy. He said, if I put a gold brick on the table, it's really impressive. There's a shock value of understanding, wow, that's really valuable.
他做了一个类比。他说：“如果我把一块金砖放在桌子上，那确实很令人印象深刻。它有一种让你明白‘哇，那真的很值钱’的冲击力。”
And then this is what he told me. He goes, if you go to Fort Knox, if you go into the vault, there's a drastically different feeling than just seeing a gold brick. Quote, "For a fly tyer, for someone who understands the feathers, and sees the potential in them, and who really has a passion-- I guess you could call it an obsession. I don't like to use it, because it sounds like a negative term-- "but that overwhelming, wow, what have I just seen feeling was all that I had. And I remember it to this point, because it was just so extraordinary. And the sad thing," he told me, "is that many, many, many-- well, most people have no idea what that feels like."
然后他告诉我：“如果你去诺克斯堡，如果你走进金库，那感觉与仅仅看到一块金砖截然不同。”他引用道：“对于一个飞蝇制作者来说，对于一个理解羽毛、看到它们潜力的、真正有激情的人——我想你可以称之为痴迷。我不喜欢用这个词，因为它听起来很负面——那种‘天哪，我刚刚看到了什么’的压倒性感受是我当时唯一的感受。直到现在我还记得这一点，因为它太不寻常了。令人悲哀的是，”他告诉我，“很多人……好吧，大多数人根本不知道那是什么感觉。”
Edwin photographed all sorts of different species of birds that day. And he says he wasn't casing the museum that first time. He just wanted to look. Except he also took pictures of the area around the museum. Those surely were not interesting photographs, but they may have proved useful later on. Oh, and also--
Edwin那天拍了各种不同种类的鸟。他说他第一次并没有在侦察博物馆。他只是想看看。但他还拍了博物馆周围区域的照片。那些照片当然没什么意思，但它们后来可能派上了用场。哦，还有……
He opens up Microsoft Word on his computer and creates a file called PlanforMuseumInvasion.doc.
他在电脑上打开微软Word，创建了一个名为“PlanforMuseumInvasion.doc”（博物馆入侵计划）的文件。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, he doesn't.
不，他没那么做。
I swear to god.
我发誓。
That's a little on the nose.
那也太显眼了。
I know. But you don't think anyone's ever going to see your hard drive, you know? In some ways, it's a smart thing to do, to build a list of the things that you're going to need to pull off a museum heist. You don't want to just wing that.
我知道。但你肯定没想过有人会看到你的硬盘，对吧？在某些方面，建立一份你需要执行博物馆盗窃案的清单是明智之举。你可不想随性而为。
Wing it? Hey-o!
随性（Wing it，双关语，Wing意为翅膀/翼）？嘿！
No, but I mean, he wrote on there that he would need a glass cutter. And I said, was this like one of those things you see in the movie where it's some perfect, disk-shaped glass that's cut?
不，我的意思是，他在上面写着他需要一把玻璃刀。我说，这是不是像你在电影里看到的那种完美的圆盘状玻璃切割？
Exactly, like in Pink Panther.
完全像《粉红豹》里的那样。
Yeah. And it was just like a handheld-- almost like an X-ACTO knife. And I was like, well, did you practice? And he's like, no. I didn't think is going to be that hard.
是的。结果只是一把手持的……几乎就像美工刀。我问：“那你练习了吗？”他说：“没。我没觉得这有多难。”
The evening of June 23, 2009, Edwin finished playing a concert at the Royal Academy of Music and boarded a train to Tring. According to him, he brought along only one empty suitcase, a pair of latex gloves he took from his doctor's office, some wire clippers, a little LED light, and the glass cutter.
2009年6月23日晚上，Edwin在皇家音乐学院演奏完一场音乐会后登上了去特林的火车。据他说，他只带了一个空手提箱、一副从他医生办公室拿来的乳胶手套、一些钢丝钳、一个小LED灯和玻璃刀。
Act Four, The Heist.
第四幕，盗窃。
So Edwin came up from the station, he's saying on foot, with his suitcase on the night. Obviously, he'd been up here before.
所以Edwin从火车站上来，他是步行，带着手提箱，在那个晚上。显然他之前来过这里。
The detective on the case, Adele Hopkin, took Kirk to the crime scene, up public footpath 37 in Tring, to a secluded area outside the museum.
案件侦探Adele Hopkin带着Kirk来到犯罪现场，沿着特林37号公共小径，到达博物馆外一个僻静区域。
--and then came along here. And then he's saying he shimmied up this wall-- which is doable-- up here onto the top.
……然后来到这里。他说他爬上了这堵墙——这是可以做到的——爬到了顶上。
He clips some strands of barbed wire in order to get to a window.
他剪断了一些带刺的铁丝网，以便进入窗户。
This window here, which has now got the bars.
就是这里现在的这扇带栏杆的窗户。
And was the reason he brought the glass cutter, which, it turns out, he dropped along the way somewhere.
他带玻璃刀的原因……结果他途中把刀掉在了某个地方。
He had a moment of doubt where he started saying to himself, maybe that's some kind of sign that I'm not supposed to do this. Like, maybe I should just bail on this whole thing. But then this other voice in his head said, no, you've been planning this forever. Just figure it out.
他曾有一刻怀疑，心想，也许这是一个标志，说明他不该这么做。就像，也许我应该放弃这件事。但随后他脑子里的另一个声音说：“不，你已经计划这件事很久了。自己想办法。”
So he used a different kind of glass cutter, a giant rock.
所以他用了另一种玻璃刀，一块大石头。
--and then just smashed one of the windows and then went in.
……然后砸碎了其中一扇窗户，进去了。
Edwin says he's not sure how he didn't cut himself up on the glass.
Edwin说他也不知道自己是怎么没被玻璃割伤的。
And an alarm is triggered in the museum. And there is a security guard there that night. This is a very contentious point, but Edwin told me that he thinks that the security guard was engrossed in a soccer match. The museum virulently denies this.
博物馆触发了警报。那天晚上有一个保安在场。这是一个非常有争议的观点，但Edwin告诉我，他认为那个保安当时正沉迷于一场足球赛。博物馆极力否认这一点。
And they told me, that particular security guard doesn't even like soccer. But one thing that we're certain of is that an alarm was triggered. The security guard did not notice it. And Edwin had the run of the place.
他们告诉我，那个特定的保安甚至不喜欢足球。但我们确定的一点是，警报被触发了。保安没有注意到。Edwin在那个地方畅通无阻。
And he was in there undetected for at least an hour. It was a weirdly easy thing to pull off. His plan had just been to take a couple of the best specimens of each species. But in the dark, with just his little LED pinch light, he couldn't see which were the best ones. So he just started grabbing whatever he could fit in his hands.
他在里面没被发现至少待了一个小时。这事做起来奇怪地简单。他的计划本是每种标本只拿最好的几个。但在黑暗中，只有小LED灯，他看不出哪些是最好的。于是他开始抓起任何能装进手里的东西。
The cotingas were small. He bagged about 100 of those. The resplendent quetzals, though, were trickier. He had to carefully coil their long tails in order to make them fit.
伞鸟很小。他装了大概100只。不过华丽绿咬鹃（resplendent quetzals）比较棘手。他不得不小心翼翼地卷起它们长长的尾巴才能装进去。
He moved from cabinet to cabinet, sometimes emptying whole drawers-- or nearly. He took 47 of the museum's 48 red-ruffed fruitcrow. He only left the last one because he didn't see it wedged in the back of the tray.
他从一个柜子转到另一个柜子，有时清空整个抽屉——或者几乎清空。他拿走了博物馆48只红绒果鸦中的47只。他只留下了最后一只，因为没看到它被楔在托盘后面。
Because he's been here before, he knew exactly where to go for what he wanted, filled up his suitcase-- you wouldn't believe it, would you-- and just walked back to the train station.
因为他之前来过，他确切知道去哪里拿想要的东西，装满了手提箱——你不敢相信吧——然后直接走回了火车站。
Kirk tried to get Edwin to describe the feeling that he had loading the birds into the suitcase. But sitting together in the hotel in Dusseldorf, Edwin was strangely devoid on this score. He told Kirk, it wasn't like, ah, they're mine now, ho, ho, ho. It was surprisingly unexciting and technical. Like, how do I make them fit?
Kirk试图让Edwin描述将鸟装进手提箱时的感觉。但在杜塞尔多夫的酒店里，Edwin在这方面表现得非常冷静。他告诉Kirk，并不是那种“哈，现在它们是我的了，嚯嚯嚯”的感觉。它出奇地无聊且技术性。就像，我该怎么装进去？
Though, he did admit that even he was amazed he managed to pull it off. Edwin said, quote, "the fact that essentially an idiot with a rock could steal a suitcase full of birds from the Natural History Museum, even as I think about it-- and I've thought about this myself-- it's absurd."
虽然他承认，即使是自己也惊讶于竟然真的做到了。Edwin说：“事实上，一个用石头的小白痴竟然能从自然历史博物馆偷走满满一箱鸟，即使现在想起来——我自己也想过——这太荒谬了。”
And then he went out the way he came in, shoved the suitcase back out of the window first, and climbed out after it. At which point, this total exhaustion fell over him, dragging one foot after the other back to town. And mixed in with the fatigue was paranoia.
然后他原路返回，先把手提箱从窗户推出去，自己再爬出来。那一刻，彻底的疲惫笼罩了他，他拖着沉重的双脚走回城里。疲惫中还夹杂着偏执。
When he got to the train platform, every set of footfalls on the walkway above him was a potential threat. And he was there for hours. He had missed the last train back to London that night and had to sit on the platform with a million dollars worth of birds until 4:00 in the morning.
当他到达火车站台时，他头顶上方人行道上的每一阵脚步声都是潜在的威胁。他在那里待了几个小时。他错过了那天晚上回伦敦的最后一班火车，不得不坐在站台上，守着价值一百万美元的鸟，直到凌晨4点。
He got back to his room, had this kind of euphoric moment where he laid out all the birds and realized the success of his haul.
他回到房间，经历了一次狂喜的时刻，把所有的鸟都摆了出来，意识到他这次收获的成功。
On the floor, or where?
在地板上还是哪？
I think he laid them out on his bed.
我想他把它们铺在床上了。
Uh-huh. Did he like roll around in the dead birds?
嗯。他有没有在死鸟身上打滚？
[LAUGHS] That, I don't know. But there was nobody else on planet Earth that had this many flawless specimens of these species. To now be sitting with this haul, like, he would punch through to the highest level of fly tying because he wouldn't want for anything. And he would just have this kind of-- you're totally in a different game now, and no one else is able to play with it, you know?
[笑] 那我不知道。但地球上没有其他人拥有这么多完美的标本。现在拥有了这些东西，他将通过飞蝇捆扎达到最高水平，因为他什么都不缺。他会有那种……你现在进入了一个完全不同的游戏，其他人没法跟你一起玩，你知道吗？
And if they wanted to play, they'd have to pay through the nose. Again, Edwin had stolen 299 birds from the museum. He would never have to wonder again where his next feather was coming from. The broken window wasn't discovered until the following morning. The cops were called in.
如果他们想玩，就必须付出高昂的代价。再说一次，Edwin从博物馆偷走了299只鸟。他再也不用担心下一根羽毛从哪来了。直到第二天早上才发现那扇破窗户。警察被叫来了。
They look around, and the museum and the cops together conclude that nothing seems to have been stolen.
他们四处查看，博物馆和警察一致认为似乎没有东西被偷。
Wait. What?
等等。什么？
Yeah. They went looking for the things that they knew had a huge market value, like Darwin's birds.
是的。他们去寻找那些他们知道有巨大市场价值的东西，比如达尔文的雀鸟。
Darwin's birds, the famous finches, which were still safely cuddled in their drawer. Once again, Alfred Wallace was second best to Darwin.
达尔文的雀鸟，那著名的雀类，仍然安全地蜷缩在它们的抽屉里。再一次，阿尔弗雷德·华莱士成了达尔文的陪衬。
Yeah.
是的。
I went through all that.
我经历了一切。
To me, it was like one of the final blows to him is that, if they had cared about Wallace as much as they should, they would have gone and checked to make sure that Wallace's birds were still there. But they didn't. And if they had done that, they would have found out right away that they had been robbed. They would have had a big head start on things. But as it happened, it took them almost-- it was well over a month before they even found out that they were robbed.
对我来说，这是给他的最后打击之一：如果他们像他们应该做的那样关心华莱士，他们就会去检查并确保华莱士的鸟还在。但他们没有。如果他们那样做了，他们会立刻发现自己被抢了。他们会抢占先机。但事实上，直到一个多月后，他们才发现自己被抢了。
35 days, in fact. The closed circuit surveillance cameras in the town of Tring reset after 28 days. In a statement to us, the museum said-- I'm paraphrasing here-- that there's nothing more important than the security and welfare of the collection. And after the theft, they changed how they grant access to the collections and also beefed up their security measures.
事实上是35天。特林镇的闭路监控摄像头在28天后就会重置。博物馆在给我们的声明中表示——我在这里概括一下——没有什么比收藏品的安全和福利更重要。盗窃发生后，他们改变了准许访问馆藏的方式，并加强了安保措施。
Act Five, The Investigation. It was only when someone wrote to the museum with a question about one of the species that a curator went to that cabinet, opened the drawer, and saw that it was empty. It was a huge blow.
第五幕，调查。直到有人写信给博物馆询问其中一种物种的问题，馆长去检查那个柜子，打开抽屉，才看到它是空的。这是一个巨大的打击。
The curators at the Tring are part of a long lineage caring for and protecting this collection. During the Blitz of London in World War II, bombs raining down everywhere, it was their predecessors who bundled up the museum's bird specimens and secreted them out of the city up to their new location in Tring. That's why they're there, so they'd be safe. And now, under the watch of collections manager Robert Prys-Jones, this happened.
特林博物馆的馆长们是保护和维护这批收藏品长期传承的一员。在二战伦敦大轰炸期间，炸弹到处落下，正是他们的前辈们把博物馆的鸟类标本打包，秘密运出城市，转移到了它们的新地点特林。这就是它们在那里的原因，为了安全。现在，在馆藏经理Robert Prys-Jones的看管下，发生了这种事。
There is a missing chunk from the record. And in something like [INAUDIBLE] bird, it is a missing chunk that-- you know, a really substantial-- possibly over the half of the world's resource of that species is now missing. The whole thing was a complete kick in the guts. It was desperately, deeply depressing.
记录中有一大块缺失。对于某些……鸟类，这是一个缺失的部分，你知道，非常严重……可能世界上超过一半的该物种资源现在都不见了。整件事完全是沉重的一击。这太令人绝望、太令人沮丧了。
Alfred Wallace's birds survived Hitler, but not Edwin Rist. The investigators didn't have a lot of obvious clues to go on. There was almost no physical evidence. But had the police or the museum looked in the visitors log, they would have found Edwin's full name, which, if someone had Googled it, they would have found edwinrist.com, on which he was selling some of their specimens, using their Latin names.
阿尔弗雷德·华莱士的鸟在希特勒的轰炸下幸存了下来，却没能躲过Edwin Rist。调查人员没有太多明显的线索。几乎没有任何物证。但如果警察或博物馆查看了访客日志，他们会发现Edwin的全名，如果有人在谷歌搜索，他们会找到 edwinrist.com，他在该网站上用这些标本的拉丁名称进行销售。
They also would have quickly discovered that he played the flute. And if they had gone looking for the birds on eBay or the fly tying forums, they would have found birds for sale from someone with the handle FlutePlayer1988. One of the posts was titled, "Indian crow feathers for sale-- buying new flute." If any of the buyers asked, Edwin made up stories as to where the birds came from. But mostly, no one asked. They didn't want to know.
他们也会很快发现他会吹长笛。如果他们去eBay或飞蝇捆扎论坛上寻找这些鸟，他们会发现一个ID叫“FlutePlayer1988”（长笛手1988）的人在卖鸟。其中一个帖子的标题是“出售印度乌鸦羽毛——买新长笛”。如果任何买家询问，Edwin会编造这些鸟的来源故事。但大多数情况下，没人问。他们不想知道。
The way Edwin finally got caught was sort of random. A tip came in from a fly tyer who had seen a bird skin at a festival-- in the Netherlands of all places-- that looked like it might have come from the Tring. And the guy traced it back to FlutePlayer1988 on eBay.
Edwin最终被抓的过程有点偶然。线索来自一位飞蝇制作者，他在荷兰的一个艺术节上看到了一个鸟皮，看起来可能来自特林博物馆。那个人顺藤摸瓜追踪到了eBay上的“FlutePlayer1988”。
It took some doing, but the police finally tracked Edwin down and showed up at his apartment with a warrant, one year after the break-in. He confessed immediately. Brought the officers into his bedroom where his girlfriend was still sleeping and showed them the birds.
费了一番功夫，警察终于追踪到Edwin，在入室盗窃发生一年后带着搜查令出现在他的公寓。他立即坦白了。他带警察走进他的卧室，当时他女朋友还在睡觉，然后向他们展示了那些鸟。
Since he confessed and plead guilty, the case went right to sentencing. Edwin was looking at 10 years for burglary and 14 years for selling stolen goods. But during the sentencing process, Edwin's lawyers brought in a psychologist who diagnosed him with Asperger's syndrome. That changed everything.
由于他认罪并服从判决，案件直接进入量刑阶段。Edwin面临10年入室盗窃刑期和14年贩卖赃物刑期。但在量刑过程中，Edwin的律师请来了一位心理学家，诊断他患有阿斯伯格综合症。这改变了一切。
The judge in his statement said that Edwin's crime wholly merited a lengthy prison sentence. He said the crime amounted to, quote, "a natural history disaster of world proportions." But he said, because of the diagnosis and a legal precedent in the UK involving Asperger's, a long prison sentence would probably be overturned on appeal. So he sentenced Edwin to one year, suspended. There was a financial penalty, too, but no time behind bars.
法官在声明中表示，Edwin的罪行完全应判长期监禁。他说这种犯罪相当于“世界级的自然历史灾难”。但他表示，由于诊断结果以及英国涉及阿斯伯格综合症的法律先例，长期刑罚在上诉中很可能会被推翻。因此，他判处Edwin缓刑一年。也有经济惩罚，但没有牢狱之灾。
Of the 299 birds, a third of them came back to the Tring unscathed. Another third had been plucked at, or dismantled, or in some way compromised. Chiefly, their bio-data tags had been removed with the date, and species, and Alfred Wallace's signature, which meant those specimens were now useless to science.
299只鸟中，有三分之一完好无损地回到了特林。另外三分之一被拔毛、拆解或以某种方式受损。主要是它们的生物数据标签被去掉了，也就是日期、物种和阿尔弗雷德·华莱士的签名，这意味着这些标本对科学来说现在没用了。
And the last third did not come back to the museum. They were gone, missing. Some of them were sold, but certainly not all of them. Where were they?
最后三分之一没有回到博物馆。它们不见了。其中一些被卖掉了，但肯定不是全部。它们在哪里？
When Edwin was caught, he pleaded his guilt, which meant that the investigation stopped, and there was no search for anything else. The museum wasn't looking for it. The British police wasn't looking for it.
当Edwin被抓获时，他认罪了，这意味着调查停止了，没有人再去搜查任何其他东西。博物馆没找，英国警察也没找。
And as I was starting to dig around in these forums-- and I would see occasions of guys cracking jokes about the heist, and it wasn't like it was a reformed community-- I was like, this is nuts. Someone's got to find these things.
当我在这些论坛上开始挖掘时，我会看到有人拿盗窃案开玩笑，这并不是一个改过自新的群体……我心想，这太疯狂了。必须有人找到这些东西。
And Kirk is someone who can't stop himself when he comes across an injustice that he might actually be able to fix. Also, this unsettling thing happened during the interview. Kirk says Edwin just didn't seem like someone with Asperger's. And after six of their eight hours together, he told him so. Edwin responded that he hadn't exhibited any obvious symptoms of the disorder until he was in the evaluation room, not long before sentencing. He said, I became exactly what I was supposed to be.
Kirk是一个在遇到可能修复的不公正时无法自拔的人。而且，采访中还发生了一件令人不安的事。Kirk说Edwin看起来根本不像有阿斯伯格综合症的人。在他们八小时采访的第六个小时后，他直接告诉了Edwin。Edwin回答说，在判决前不久去评估室之前，他没有表现出任何明显的障碍症状。他说：“我变成了他们预期的样子。”
If I'm being honest, I was pissed off. Like, this started out as just a quirky, funny story to me. But when I learned about Wallace, when I learned about the debt that we have to these specimen collections and that they were still out there-- a lot of them were still missing-- then it took on a more serious valence where suddenly I was like, OK, this isn't just like a funny thing. You can't go back and get another bird from 1860 anymore. That bird's gone.
老实说，我很生气。这起初对我来说只是一个古怪、有趣的故事。但当我了解到华莱士，当我了解到我们对这些标本收藏负有的债务，以及它们仍然流落在外——很多依然下落不明——它就带上了一种更严肃的色彩，我突然心想，好吧，这不仅仅是一件有趣的事情。你无法回头再去获取1860年的鸟了。那只鸟已经消失了。
And what I met was a kid who was not remorseful, who kind of grimaced when I referred to him as a thief at one point. And he told me that he doesn't think of himself as a thief. Are we at the anger level at this point? Like, probably approaching there. Because now it's as if this is a case closed. And no one's looking for these birds. And I'm still on these forums seeing people trading and selling things that look suspiciously like Edwin's birds.
我遇到的是一个毫无悔意的孩子，当我在某个时刻称他为“贼”时，他甚至皱了皱眉。他告诉我他认为自己不是贼。我们当时已经到了愤怒的边缘了吗？大概差不多了。因为现在这就像一个结案的案子，没人再找这些鸟了。而我仍然在这些论坛上看到人们交易和出售看起来非常像Edwin那些鸟的东西。
Had Edwin hidden a bunch away and was still selling them? Was someone else selling them? Kirk couldn't let it go. And then he had a kind of breakthrough and became certain that he knew where all of the missing specimens were.
Edwin是否藏起了一堆并在继续销售？是别人在卖吗？Kirk无法放下这件事。然后他有了一个突破，确信自己知道那些失踪标本都在哪里。
Coming up, Kirk goes and confronts his prime suspect. And he learns that ornithologists can have serious potty mouths. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，Kirk去质问他的头号嫌疑人。他发现鸟类学家可能会说出非常粗鲁的脏话。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的报道。
It's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole in for Ira Glass. Today's show, the Feather Heist, the true story of one of the weirdest capers in recent history, which was also a tragic loss to natural history. And it's the story of Kirk Johnson, who took it upon himself to re-investigate the theft of 299 bird specimens from the Tring Museum north of London.
这是《美国生活》。我是Sean Cole，代替Ira Glass主持。今天的节目是《羽毛盗窃案》，这是近现代史上最怪异的盗窃案之一的真实故事，这也是自然历史的一个悲剧性损失。这也是Kirk Johnson的故事，他自行重新调查了从伦敦北部的特林博物馆窃取299只鸟类标本的案件。
Act Six, The Suspect. Kirk, of course, asked Edwin Rist about the missing bird skins when they were together in Dusseldorf. Edwin told him the police took everything from him. They had everything.
第六幕，嫌疑人。Kirk当然在杜塞尔多夫和Edwin在一起时问过他失踪的鸟皮。Edwin告诉他，警察拿走了他的一切。他们拿走了一切。
He also, in the interview, called into question whether the museum knew how many were still missing and suggested they never really knew how many they had in the first place. But the people at the Tring had given Kirk this document, a meticulous accounting of what had come back to them and what was still unaccounted for. And Kirk had it with him. This is him reading it to Edwin in the hotel room.
他在采访中也对博物馆是否知道还有多少失踪表示怀疑，并暗示他们根本不知道自己有多少馆藏。但特林博物馆的人给了Kirk这份文件，一份关于什么回到了他们手里、什么依然下落不明的细致会计账目。Kirk带着它。这是他在酒店房间里读给Edwin听。
I mean, this is like a pretty thorough-- like the number of specimens missing July '09, intact specimen was labelled-- without label. Approximate number of specimens represented by feathers and skin fragments, and then a total estimate sort of consolidated. I know this is weird.
我是说，这相当彻底……比如2009年7月缺失的标本数量，完整标本是有标签的……无标签的。由羽毛和皮肤碎片代表的近似标本数量，以及汇总的预估总数。我知道这很奇怪。
I said, this doesn't seem haphazard. And Edwin said, no, it doesn't seem haphazard. I would agree. It looks very, very thorough. And it looks very calculated, I guess.
我说，这看起来并不草率。Edwin说：“不，这看起来并不草率。我同意。它看起来非常、非常彻底。而且我觉得它看起来经过非常精密的计算。”
And so I said, well, so then, if that's accurate, where are they? And he goes, if someone has them, I really don't know about it. And the question then is, does one individual have them? Or is it parceled out over time?
所以我说，好的，如果这是准确的，那它们在哪？他说：“如果有人有它们，我真的不知道。问题是，是一个人拥有它们吗？还是随着时间分散了？”
And I look up at him. And I said, but aren't you the person most uniquely positioned to answer that? And he says, in what sense?
我抬头看着他，说：“但你不是最有资格回答这个问题的人吗？”他说：“什么意思？”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I looked at him. I was like, but you're the one that took them. And after kind of a long-winded response, he said, I don't have them, fundamentally.
我看着他，心想，但你是拿走它们的人。在经过一段长篇大论的回答后，他说：“本质上，我没有它们。”
He used the word fundamentally?
他用了“本质上”这个词？
Yes.
是的。
Now, a number of Edwin's customers returned the feathers, and bird parts, and whole birds that they'd bought from him to the museum. In some cases, Edwin's dad reimbursed them, spending thousands of dollars. The museum was now faced with the bizarre task of having to calculate how many feathers equaled one red-ruffed fruitcrow.
现在，Edwin的一些客户把他们买的羽毛、鸟的身体部位和完整的鸟退回给了博物馆。在某些情况下，Edwin的父亲报销了他们的费用，花了数千美元。博物馆现在面临一项离奇的任务，必须计算多少根羽毛等于一只红绒果鸦。
And factoring all of that in, the number of outstanding birds on the spreadsheet shrank down to 64. And as Kirk waded through all of the past sales of birds online, doing Wayback Machine searches and stuff like that, this sort of pattern started to emerge that seemed odd. There was another user who had clearly posted specimens that came from Edwin's stash.
考虑到所有这些，电子表格上未结标本的数量缩小到64只。当Kirk梳理所有网上过去的鸟类销售记录、查看Wayback Machine等网页存档时，这种奇怪的模式开始显现。有另一个用户明显发布了来自Edwin库存的标本。
This different user named Goku, G-O-K-U.
这个不同的用户叫 Goku（悟空）。
Either it was Edwin under another name, or someone who was working with him to sell the birds, an accomplice.
要么是Edwin化名，要么是协助他销售这些鸟的人，一个同伙。
And I really did not know the answer for a long time. But this Goku guy suddenly became like a big person of interest to me.
在很长一段时间里我真的不知道答案。但这个叫悟空的家伙突然成了我关注的重要人物。
Kirk started mapping all of Edwin's closest associates in the fly tying world. And he developed a short list as to who Goku might be, if it wasn't Edwin. And then one day, Kirk happened to be visiting with an ornithologist at Yale named Rick Prum, one of the head curators at the Peabody Museum.
Kirk开始梳理Edwin在飞蝇捆扎世界中最亲密的伙伴，并列出了一份关于悟空可能是谁的短名单。然后有一天，Kirk恰好去拜访耶鲁大学的一位鸟类学家Rick Prum，他是皮博迪博物馆的首席馆长之一。
MacArthur Genius Guggenheim recipient. And you walk in, and he's just like dropping the F-bomb right and left.
麦克阿瑟天才奖和古根海姆奖得主。你走进去，他一直在说F开头的脏话。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he's just-- I mean, I love this guy.
我真的爱死这家伙了。
And I wrote these notes, because I was trying to get Fish and Wildlife Service to bust these fuckers.
我写下了这些笔记，因为我想让鱼类及野生动物管理局抓捕这些混蛋。
Rick Prum had taken an enraged interest in the Tring case himself. Like Kirk, he had taken copious notes, kept track of the sales online. And listening to the two of them talk, it's like they've each met the only other person in the world who's not only heard of but loves just as passionately the same band he worshipped in high school.
Rick Prum本人也对特林案产生了愤怒的兴趣。像Kirk一样，他做了大量的笔记，追踪了网上的销售记录。听着他们俩谈话，感觉就像他们各自遇到了世界上唯一一个不仅听说过、而且同样热情地爱着他高中时崇拜的同一个乐队的人。
I mean, did you ever see Rist-- you never saw his website at the day? Like, when he was busted, what was on his website?
我是说，你见过Rist……你没见过他当天的网站吗？他被捕时，他网站上有什么？
His website's down now.
他的网站现在打不开了。
Yeah, but did you ever record it?
是的，但你录下来过吗？
No.
没有。
I have. I've got his whole website,
我有。我抓取了他的整个网站。
All those screenshots?
那些截图？
Yeah.
对。
No way.
不会吧。
And looking at Edwin's website definitively narrowed the short list of who Goku who might be down to one guy.
看着Edwin的网站，最终将悟空是谁的名单锁定到了一个人身上。
OK, right there, Long Nguyen.
好的，就在这儿，Long Nguyen（龙阮）。
Long Nguyen, another top-notch fly tyer who is exactly Edwin's age. They're friends. Long Nguyen lives in Norway.
Long Nguyen，另一位顶尖的飞蝇制作者，年龄正好和Edwin一样。他们是朋友。Long Nguyen住在挪威。
Oh yes, it's so perfect. You have no idea how helpful that is.
哦，太完美了。你不知道这有多大帮助。
Wow. I mean, this is why I did it.
哇。我的意思是，这就是我做这件事的原因。
And Kirk had other evidence implicating Long, some Facebook exchanges, Edwin saying, did your box arrive, pictures of the two of them on a trip to Japan after which all kinds of new birds were posted for sale by Goku. Not only that, other members of the community were openly accusing Long of working with Edwin, telling him, we know it's you. Your days are numbered.
Kirk还有其他暗示Long参与的证据，一些Facebook交流，Edwin说“你的包裹到了吗？”，还有他们去日本旅行的照片，之后悟空发布了各种新鸟类进行销售。不仅如此，该群体的其他成员公开指责Long与Edwin合作，告诉他：“我们知道是你。你的日子不多了。”
Now, Edwin has insisted all along that Long was not involved in the heist. He's defended Long against accusations on the internet. And he told Kirk that Long was not involved. And then he put Kirk in touch with Long. And Long, the only other person Kirk knew of who clearly seemed to be selling the stolen birds, agreed to talk.
现在，Edwin一直坚称Long没有参与盗窃。他在互联网上为Long辩护，反驳指控。他告诉Kirk，Long没有参与。然后他让Kirk联系了Long。Long，Kirk知道的唯一另一个看起来显然在卖被盗鸟类的人，同意交谈。
Act Seven, Oslo. Kirk thought maybe Long had been at the museum with Edwin that night. There was always a question as to how Edwin pulled this off on his own. Maybe Long had put him up to it in the first place. He pictured him being wealthy and manipulative, using Edwin as a pawn.
第七幕，奥斯陆。Kirk心想，也许Long那天晚上和Edwin一起在博物馆。关于Edwin是如何独自完成这一切的一直是个问题。也许是Long最初唆使他的。他想象Long富有且善于操纵，把Edwin当作棋子。
And when Kirk's plane landed in Oslo, he was just about jumping out of his skin he was so eager to talk with Long. He took a train out to a little suburb of the city. Long met him at the station. He was a teenage-looking 20-something with a big smile and Chuck Taylors.
当Kirk的飞机降落在奥斯陆时，他因为太想和Long谈谈而激动得几乎要跳起来。他坐火车去了城市的一个小郊区。Long在车站接他。他看起来像个十几岁的20岁出头的小伙子，带着灿烂的笑容，穿着Chuck Taylor帆布鞋。
I had miraculously convinced him to do the interview at his home because I had this kind of fantastical notion that he would slip up, and I would find some partially-exposed wing under the couch or something like that, you know?
我奇迹般地说服了他接受采访，地点在他家里，因为我有一种幻想，认为他会说漏嘴，我会发现沙发下藏着部分露出的翅膀之类的东西。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like a box of dead birds would come tumbling out of a closet.
就像一箱死鸟会从壁橱里滚出来一样。
Yeah, when he was trying to reach for some sugar packets or something. So we walk into the apartment, and out of the corner of my eye there's like this green flash just bombing towards my face. And it's his parrot that just was loose in the apartment and flapped over and landed on my shoulder and spent most of the-- I think that was like a seven-hour interview the first day.
是的，当他试图拿糖包之类的东西时。我们走进公寓，眼角余光看到一只绿色的东西径直向我的脸扑来。那是他在公寓里散养的鹦鹉，飞过来落在了我的肩膀上，第一天那七个小时的采访大部分时间都在这儿。
And it was an uncomfortable interview where I'm learning all of these things about his life, but also confronting him with stuff. And his bird is, meanwhile, kind of nibbling on my earlobe.
那是一场令人尴尬的采访，我了解了他生活中的所有这些事情，但也用东西与他对质。而他的鹦鹉同时在咬我的耳垂。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I hope I'm not being like [PARROT SQUAWKS] a jerk or like-- I feel like the worst [PARROT SQUAWKS] guest ever asking all these questions.
我希望我没有像个混蛋……或者……我感觉自己是最差劲的客人，问了这么多问题。
No, but those are questions I--
不，但那些是我……的问题。
And something else happened when Kirk walked into the apartment. All notions of Long being the rich, conniving mastermind of the Tring heist fell away. Long was from a family of Vietnamese refugees who had fled the war to Norway in the '70s. He started tying flies in a boys home when he was a kid, basically as an escape.
还有一件事发生在Kirk走进公寓时。所有关于Long是特林盗窃案富有、阴险的策划者的想法都消失了。Long来自一个越南难民家庭，70年代为了躲避战争逃到了挪威。他小时候是在一个男童收容所开始绑飞蝇的，基本上是为了逃避现实。
--because things were turbulent in our family. I mean, yeah, I don't think about that now because it's past. But things were bad. We had our best to just go through it with parents being in Vietnam and all, and after the war and stuff.
……因为我们家的情况很混乱。我是说，是的，我现在不想想这个，因为那都是过去的事了。但情况很糟糕。父母在越南，战争结束后，我们尽力度过难关。
And Long said he never really had what he called true friends. And around that same time after he had started tying flies, he was reading about other fly tyers online. And he heard about this one kid in America who was exactly his age.
Long说他从来没有过所谓的真正的朋友。在大约那个时候，在他开始绑飞蝇后，他在网上读到了其他飞蝇制作者的故事。他听说美国有一个孩子正好和他同岁。
I think I start hearing about Edwin when I was 15 or 16, because he was really famous back then.
我想我15或16岁时开始听说Edwin，因为他那时非常出名。
Long looked up to Edwin. They met online first, just writing back and forth. They had a ton in common, so they decided to meet. And that Japan trip was the first time they saw each other in person. They tied flies together there. Edwin had already stolen the birds at that point, but he hadn't been caught yet.
Long很崇拜Edwin。他们先是在网上认识，只是互通邮件。他们有很多共同点，所以决定见面。日本之旅是他们第一次亲自见面。他们在那里一起绑飞蝇。Edwin那时已经偷了鸟，但还没被抓。
And he's telling me that Edwin reached out to him to ask him to help sell these things, but just as a friend. He just said, hey, I found these things. Can you post these things online for me?
他告诉我，Edwin联系他请求帮忙出售这些东西，但只是作为朋友。他只是说：“嘿，我发现了一些东西。你能帮我在网上发布这些吗？”
And Long thought that that was what being a friend was. He thought he was going to help Edwin make enough money to buy his new flute. And he also felt really flattered and honored that Edwin Rist was paying attention to him.
Long认为这就是做朋友的意义。他以为自己是在帮Edwin赚够钱买新长笛。而且Edwin Rist能关注他，也让他感到受宠若惊和荣幸。
Long told Kirk he mostly just re-posted some of Edwin's ads, including pictures of birds. But it is true that Edwin sent him a bunch of presorted packets of feathers and three or four whole bird skins to sell. And Long did sell some of them, but Long says he didn't know any of it was stolen at the time, which Edwin confirms.
Long告诉Kirk，他大部分只是重新发布了一些Edwin的广告，包括鸟类照片。但确实Edwin寄给他了一堆预先分拣好的羽毛包和三四张完整的鸟皮让他卖。Long卖掉了一些，但Long说他在那时不知道这全是偷来的，Edwin证实了这一点。
Edwin made up stories about where the birds came from. And Long never stopped to think how implausible they were, partly because he was blinded by his love of the birds. But also, probably he was blinded by his infatuation for Edwin. Looking back, Long says Edwin was probably just trying to attract less attention to himself.
Edwin编造了这些鸟的来源故事。Long从来没有停下来想过这些故事有多么不可信，部分原因是他的眼睛被对鸟类的爱蒙蔽了。但可能他也因对Edwin的迷恋而失明。回想起来，Long说Edwin可能只是想尽量减少对自己的关注。
My assumption is just like he wanted to erase his traces. But the traces were already there, so I don't know why.
我的假设就是他想抹去痕迹。但痕迹已经在那儿了，所以我不知道为什么。
But he's using you as a friend.
但他在把你当作朋友利用。
Yeah.
是的。
Like he's-- do you see what-- it's not a nice thing to do.
你看，这不是一件好事。
No, it's absolutely not. And I had like a tough decision about how to deal with this friendship. At the time, I think, when he get exposed, I was really shocked. I was frozen from the forum because people-- they assumed that I was the one responsible for everything. I was considering if I should turn my back, because it's reasonable for me to erase this friendship. And you can't do this to friends.
不，这绝对不是。我曾经面临一个艰难的决定，如何处理这段友谊。当时，我想，当他被曝光时，我真的很震惊。我被论坛封杀了，因为人们假设我是对所有事情负责的那个人。我考虑过是否应该背弃他，因为抹去这段友谊对我来说是合理的。你不能对朋友做这种事。
It made me really upset with Edwin. I don't know how you look at this chain of events and see them as equals. I don't know how you look at the chain of events and see this as anything other than Edwin using him as a fence to potentially take the fall for him if things got hairy.
这让我对Edwin感到非常生气。我不知道你如何看待这一系列事件并将他们视为对等的。我不知道你怎么能把这一系列事件仅仅视为Edwin利用他作为一个挡箭牌，在事情变得棘手时让他顶罪。
Sitting with Long, Kirk ultimately turned to the question of where the missing birds were. But instead of just asking him outright, he eased into the subject with a kind of Colombo, just-one-more-question gentle persistence.
和Long坐在一起，Kirk最终转向了失踪鸟类在哪里的话题。但他没有直接问他，而是以一种像科伦坡（Colombo）侦探那样，“还有一个问题”般的温柔坚持深入了这个话题。
Meanwhile, Long sometimes sounded like a disgraced banker at a congressional hearing, saying he couldn't remember things that seemed basic. For instance, Kirk asked him whether the customers paid Edwin directly, or if Long had handled any of the money.
与此同时，Long有时听起来像国会听证会上丢了职位的银行家，声称记不起看似基本的事情。例如，Kirk问他客户是直接付钱给Edwin，还是Long处理了任何钱款。
I don't remember if I received the money, or if the money went to him.
我不记得是我收到了钱，还是钱直接给了他。
You remember, right? I mean, I'm not trying to be an asshole, but you would remember if people-- like, these things were selling for thousands of dollars.
你记得，对吧？我是说，我不想当个混蛋，但如果人们……这些东西卖数千美元……你会记得的。
Yeah--
是的……
Don't you think you would remember?
你不觉得你会记得吗？
I don't think I sold things for thousands of dollars. What I remember most is selling small amounts, like packages of feathers.
我不认为我卖了数千美元的东西。我记得最清楚的是卖了一些小额的东西，比如羽毛包。
I don't want to be rude, but this is another point where I'm really just--
我不想粗鲁，但这是另一个我真的感到……的点。
Yeah, I understand. Because I spent like four years to try to forget all this.
是的，我明白。因为我花了四年时间试图忘记这一切。
Yeah.
是。
Yeah. So what are you doing, it's like try to bring up all in the surface. So the details is quite unclear to myself, because I trying to close this case.
是的。所以你在做什么，就像试图把这一切都带回表面。细节对我自己来说很不清晰，因为我试图结案。
Yeah, Kirk thought to himself, you and me both, buddy.
是啊，Kirk心想，咱们俩都一样，伙计。
There are still a lot of skins that are missing.
还有很多鸟皮缺失。
Yeah.
是的。
Like a lot.
很多。
Yeah.
是的。
[PARROT SQUAWKS]
[鹦鹉尖叫]
I don't have any skins. Many people would probably think that I possess those skins.
我没有任何鸟皮。很多人可能会认为我拥有那些鸟皮。
Why?
为什么？
Because I was so close related to Edwin. That would be a natural thing to assume.
因为我和Edwin关系太紧密了。这会是一个很自然的假设。
It would be very logical.
这非常有逻辑。
Yeah.
是的。
Like pretty reasonable for them to think that, no?
对他们来说，这么想相当合理，不是吗？
Yeah. That's what I'm saying.
是的。这就是我想说的。
Yeah. If that's not true, than, A, how can we prove that that's not true?
是啊。如果那不是真的，那么，A，我们怎么证明那不是真的？
I can't prove it.
我无法证明。
You can or you can't?
你行还是不行？
Can't.
不行。
Then the question, B, is, where are they?
那么问题B是，它们在哪里？
Where? I don't know.
哪里？我不知道。
How is that possible? How do you not know? Like, you know-- like, I mean, you and Edwin--
怎么可能？你怎么会不知道？你和Edwin……
I know what Ed-- like, I don't know where because a tiny part was sold through me. You can't ask for a receipt for me not having skins.
我知道Edwin……我不知道在哪里，因为极小一部分是通过我卖掉的。你不能要求我提供我没有这些鸟皮的收据。
Kirk left Long's apartment feeling bad for him, but also frustrated. It still seemed like maybe he was holding something back. And he didn't know if he would ever see Long again.
Kirk离开Long的公寓时为他感到难过，但也感到沮丧。看起来他可能依然有所保留。他不知道自己是否还会再见到Long。
But then, the next morning, Long was waiting for Kirk in the lobby of his hotel. He told Kirk he had been thinking and decided to quit tying flies with exotic bird feathers. He was afraid, though, that he'd lose the few friends he still had. He said they only liked him because he tied beautiful flies.
但第二天早上，Long在酒店大堂等Kirk。他告诉Kirk，他一直在思考，并决定停止用珍稀鸟类的羽毛绑飞蝇。不过他很害怕失去他仅有的几个朋友。他说他们喜欢他只是因为他能绑出漂亮的飞蝇。
Kirk and Long spent the next two days hanging out. They walked around the city together, mostly sightseeing. And at one point, they met up on the steps of the National Gallery where Munch's painting, The Scream, was stolen in 1994 by thieves who broke through a window.
Kirk和Long接下来的两天都在一起。他们一起在城里闲逛，主要是观光。在某个时刻，他们在国家美术馆的台阶上见了面，蒙克的画作《呐喊》就是1994年盗贼打破窗户从那里偷走的。
And I just decided like, ah, screw it. I'm going to just do one more attack on his defenses here and see if I can get him to admit anything.
我决定，去他的。我要对他再做一次防御攻击，看看能不能让他承认什么。
I heard from two separate people that, in the last year, you've told them that you have so much Indian crow, and you don't have any need for it. And so, what am I supposed to do with that?
我从两个人那里听说，去年你告诉他们你有太多的印度乌鸦羽毛，你根本用不完。所以，我该拿这个怎么办？
You do whatever you--
你想怎么办就……
But is it true?
但这属实吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That you have a lot of Indian crow?
你有很多印度乌鸦羽毛？
No. I have, like-- I still have some of the packages of the ones I was supposed to sell.
不。我还有……我还有一些本来要卖的包裹。
OK.
好吧。
Long kept those packages he was supposed to sell for himself, after Edwin was arrested. He sent back the bird skins, but he kept the feathers.
Edwin被捕后，Long把那些本该卖掉的包裹留给了自己。他退还了鸟皮，但留下了羽毛。
And suddenly, I was like, OK, now we're getting somewhere.
突然，我心想，好吧，现在我们要有进展了。
Like, how many?
有多少？
And he was just miserable under this line of questioning, but he finally estimated that he had between 600 and 800 of these feathers from Edwin.
他在这种质问下显得非常痛苦，但他最终估计他手里还有600到800根来自Edwin的这些羽毛。
But 800 is a lot of feathers.
但800根羽毛非常多。
Yeah, I know.
是的，我知道。
And he didn't have that many anymore. He had sold half of them-- again, back before he knew they were stolen-- and kept the rest, which he had been tying with ever since. He was now down to about 100 feathers.
他手里没有那么多了。他卖掉了一半——同样是在知道它们是偷来的之前——剩下的他一直用来绑飞蝇。现在只剩下大约100根羽毛了。
Kirk says Long also admitted that the number of birds Edwin sent him was more like 10 or 20, rather than just a few. We checked this with Long, and he refutes it. In any case, Kirk finally felt like he was closing in on what he'd been after.
Kirk说Long还承认Edwin寄给他的鸟的数量更多是10到20只，而不是几只。我们和Long核实过这一点，他反驳了。无论如何，Kirk终于感觉自己快要达到目的了。
Obviously, he had no real standing to be asking any of these questions or making demands. He wasn't the police. He didn't work for the museum. But he had been on this case so doggedly for so long.
显然，他没有任何真正的主张去问这些问题或提出要求。他不是警察。他不为博物馆工作。但他一直如此坚持不懈地追踪这个案子太久了。
I was like, Long, you know you have to show me these things, right? And he kind of very quietly said, yes. And then he started crying. And he--
我说：“Long，你知道你必须把这些给我看，对吧？”他非常安静地说：“是的。”然后他开始哭。他……
He started crying?
他开始哭？
Yeah, and he told me he's never told anyone about this, that not even his family knows about this, that he's never admitted this to anyone. And I saw someone who was really struggling with his actions in a way that I hadn't seen with Edwin. There were no tears in the Edwin interview.
是的，他告诉我他从来没有告诉过任何人，甚至连他的家人都不知道这件事，他从来没有向任何人承认过。我看到了一个真正与自己的行为作斗争的人，这与我在采访Edwin时看到的不同。Edwin采访时没有眼泪。
Right.
对。
I mean, there was a kind of a-- he thought it was just as crazy as I did-- this whole story-- attitude, you know?
我的意思是，他有一种……他认为这和我看到的一样疯狂——整个故事的态度，你知道吗？
So not only are you getting a better accounting of their co-involvement and the number of birds that were involved, but also there's something else that you've been looking for, which is like contrition, kind of.
所以你不仅对他们的共同参与和涉及的鸟类数量有了更好的核算，而且你一直在寻找的还有别的东西，那就是……忏悔。
Yeah. Yeah.
是的，是的。
Kirk and Long took the train back to Long's apartment where Long dipped in and fetched his binder of feathers, sort of like a stamp book with little pockets. They brought it to a local bar, ordered a couple of beers, and opened it.
Kirk和Long坐火车回到Long的公寓，Long拿出了他的羽毛夹，就像带有小口袋的邮票册一样。他们带到当地一家酒吧，点了两杯啤酒，打开了它。
Can I take pictures?
我可以拍照吗？
Sure.
当然。
I want to ask you just like, what's what, kind of.
我只想问你，什么是什么。
And four years after he had first heard about the heist, Kirk had them in his hands, feathers that no one else knew about, that Edwin Rist had stolen from the Tring Museum. It was the first time he had seen stolen Tring Museum feathers in the wild, fugitive feathers. Kirk says holding that binder, he felt a straight line back to Wallace, Wallace who wrote, "All living things were not made for man." Still, Wallace probably never pictured two guys poring over the detached feathers of his birds in a bar in suburban Oslo.
在听说盗窃案四年后，Kirk终于把它们拿在手里了，那是没人知道的羽毛，Edwin Rist从特林博物馆偷走的羽毛。这是他第一次在野外看到失窃的特林博物馆羽毛，逃亡的羽毛。Kirk说拿着那个文件夹，他感到了一条直通华莱士的线索，华莱士曾写道：“一切生物并非为人类而造。”然而，华莱士可能从未想象过两个人在奥斯陆郊区的一家酒吧里仔细研究他那些鸟的残余羽毛。
So this is like-- these are Tring, and this is--
所以这些是……这些是特林的，这些不是。
This is Tring, this is not Tring.
这是特林的，这个不是。
OK.
好的。
This is Tring.
这是特林的。
OK, so there's like--
好的，所以有……
Should we just count only the Tring first?
我们先只数特林的？
Yeah.
行。
And then I'll tell about every feather.
然后我会告诉你每一根羽毛。
Yeah, that'd be great.
太棒了。
OK. 1, 2, 3, 4 , 5, 6, 7--
好的。1、2、3、4、5、6、7……
And I just remember very clearly having two thoughts. One was, here they are. I found them.
我记得很清楚当时有两种想法。一个是：它们就在这里，我找到了。
And how can you tell so quickly which ones are Tring?
你怎么能这么快看出哪些是特林的？
Wait. Wait.
等等，等等。
OK, sorry. You're at 40 there.
好的，抱歉。你数到40了。
40?
40？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
One.
1。
And then, at the same time, recognizing just how pathetic it all was and how small it all was. There wasn't a box of missing birds. There were no labels. These things, I knew what happened. They're just plucked, harvested feathers from 150-year-old birds that will never be returned to their-- you can't reattach them to a bird. You can't do anything with them. And so it was this complicated moment where I was really kind of proud, but also a little embarrassed. Because I was like, this is not-- there's nothing really triumphant about this moment.
然后，与此同时，认识到这一切是多么可怜和渺小。没有一箱缺失的鸟。没有标签。这些东西，我知道发生了什么。它们只是从150年前的鸟身上拔下来的、收获的羽毛，永远无法回到它们……你无法把它们重新粘回鸟身上。你对它们什么也做不了。所以那是一个复杂的时刻，我既感到自豪，也感到有点尴尬。因为我心想，这并不是……这个时刻并没有什么真正值得胜利的东西。
Kirk told Long he thought Long should send the feathers back to the museum, partly because it might help Long put the whole ugly business behind him. And Long agreed. It took him a few months, but he finally stuffed them all into an envelope with no return address.
Kirk告诉Long他认为Long应该把羽毛退回给博物馆，部分原因是因为这可能有助于Long把整个丑陋的生意抛在身后。Long同意了。花了他几个月时间，他最终把它们全部塞进了一个没有回邮地址的信封里。
Kirk learned of two other full bird skins that definitively came from the Tring. The buyer lives in South Africa and has no interest in sending them back. About 20 others belonging to a guy in Montreal looked like possible Tring birds, but he's resold them already.
Kirk得知还有两张完整的鸟皮明确来自特林。买家住在南非，对寄回没有任何兴趣。另外20张属于蒙特利尔的一个人，看起来可能是特林的鸟，但他已经转售了。
And say Long sold 10 more of them. That would bring the total number of birds unaccounted for down to 32, which means, A, there's just no way to find out what happened to all of them anymore. And B, Edwin is not the only fly tyer in the world who felt OK about knowingly owning stolen property.
假设Long又卖了10只。那剩下的下落不明的鸟总数降至32只，这意味着：A，现在已经没法知道它们怎么了。B，Edwin并不是世界上唯一一个乐于故意拥有被盗财产的飞蝇制作者。
Anyone who bought anything from him should send it back to the museum in whatever shape it's in.
任何从他那里买东西的人都应该以任何形式将其退还给博物馆。
But what would come of them sending back parts of birds, or feathers, or whatever?
但他们退回鸟的身体部位或羽毛，能有什么结果呢？
Nothing.
什么都没有。
没有？
No scientific value. I mean, maybe someone will figure out down the line how to figure out which feather came from which bird, but it would just be a moral victory, honestly.
没有科学价值。我的意思是，也许将来有人会找出方法来判断哪根羽毛来自哪只鸟，但这老实说只是一场道德上的胜利。
A moral victory?
道德上的胜利？
Yeah. I mean, it's not-- and I'm fully aware of that. Like, they're not going to be used, but they don't belong to this community. They belong to that museum. And the end of this should be everyone just return things that they know are stolen, even if it's two feathers. And they can walk around with their head a little bit higher. And maybe that's just so stupid of me for suggesting this. But if the choice is between them returning it and them getting to keep it, that seems easy to me.
是的。我的意思是，它不是……我完全意识到了这一点。它们不会被使用，但它们不属于这个群体，它们属于那个博物馆。这一切的终点应该是每个人都退还他们知道是偷来的东西，即使只是两根羽毛。他们可以昂首挺胸。也许我这么建议太蠢了。但如果在退还和保留之间做选择，这对我来说似乎很容易。
But Kirk finally decided to let go of this case. He realized that he had become just as obsessive as Edwin about the birds and as obsessive as Wallace, for that matter. All three men, for completely different reasons, spent years fixating over the very same birds-- not the same species, the same physical animals.
但Kirk最终决定放弃这个案子。他意识到自己已经变得和Edwin一样沉迷于鸟类，或者说和华莱士一样沉迷了。这三个人，出于完全不同的原因，多年来盯着同样的鸟——不是物种，而是同样的实体动物。
Wallace wanted knowledge. Edwin saw a lot of beautiful colors and guessed dollar signs. And Kirk, though he knows how loony this sounds, wanted to avenge the birds.
华莱士想要知识。Edwin看到了大量的绚丽色彩，想的是美元符号。而Kirk，尽管他知道这听起来有多疯狂，却想为这些鸟复仇。
As a last-ditch effort, and with the museum's knowledge, he went on the main fly tying forum and said that the Tring was ready to accept any anonymous returns, no questions asked. He said, as much as I would personally like to know who might be in possession of any of the missing skins, it is much more important that they be returned. And I have included the museum's address below for anyone who is so inclined.
作为最后的尝试，在博物馆的知情下，他来到主要的飞蝇捆扎论坛，说特林博物馆准备接受任何匿名退还，不追究任何问题。他说：“尽管我个人很想知道谁可能拥有任何缺失的鸟皮，但退还它们要重要得多。我已在下方附上博物馆的地址，供任何有此意向的人使用。”
I don't mean to lecture-- and I imagine that some of you might be annoyed by this point-- but I am challenging you to help remove this cloud that hangs over your hobby. Simply deleting any reference to what happened at the Tring doesn't seem like the best way of coming to terms with it. And then, more than 40 members of the fly tying community asked the moderator of the forum to delete Kirk's post. And like so many other things in this story, it disappeared.
我不是想说教——我知道你们中的一些人此时可能会很恼火——但我正在挑战你们，帮助驱散悬在你们爱好上空的这片阴云。简单地删除关于特林发生之事的任何参考，似乎不是达成共识的最佳方式。然后，飞蝇捆扎群体的40多名成员要求论坛版主删除了Kirk的帖子。就像这个故事中的许多其他事情一样，它消失了。
Kirk Johnson wrote an excellent book about the museum heist, which was the basis for this story. It has lots of details that we weren't able to get into on the radio. It's called The Feather Thief-- Beauty, Obsession, and the Natural History Heist of the Century.
Kirk Johnson写了一本关于博物馆盗窃案的优秀著作，这也是本故事的基础。它有很多我们在电台上无法涉及的细节。书名是《羽毛窃贼——美丽、痴迷与世纪自然历史盗窃案》。
Our program is produced today by Miki Meek. The people who help make our show-- Dana Chivvis, Neil Drumming, Damian Gray, Hannah Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Anna Martin, Robin Simeon, Christopher Switala, Stowe Nelson, Julia Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed, managing editor, Susan Burton, research help from Michelle Harris. Special thanks today to Ellen Paul, James Costa, and Marion Bentley.
我们的节目由Miki Meek制作。帮助制作我们节目的还有：Dana Chivvis, Neil Drumming, Damian Gray, Hannah Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Anna Martin, Robin Simeon, Christopher Switala, Stowe Nelson, Julia Whitaker 和 Diane Wu。我们的资深制作人是Brian Reed，主编 Susan Burton，研究助理 Michelle Harris。今天特别感谢 Ellen Paul, James Costa 和 Marion Bentley。
Our website is thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes, totally free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass.
我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600集的存档。本节目由公共广播交换中心 PRX 传输给公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我的老板 Ira Glass。
You know, I happened to see him in the park last weekend with his two dogs, a labradoodle and a Pomeranian. It was just the three of them walking along. And he got really hostile when I approached them.
你知道，上周末我碰巧在公园里看到他带着他的两条狗，一只拉布拉多贵宾犬和一只博美犬。就他们三个走在一起。当我走近他们时，他变得非常充满敌意。
We're a small, tight-knit community. And you do not want to piss us off.
我们是一个小而紧密的群体。你不会想惹恼我们的。
I'm Sean Cole. Ira's back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Sean Cole。Ira下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。